[Music]
foreign
YouTube channel do subscribe if you love
a bit of misogyny and narcissism today
we're talking Jonah Hill and his
ex-girlfriend who's decided to LEAP
messages after he welcomed a baby with
his new girlfriend I see a new
girlfriend she's been there for a while
today I'm gonna try and be a bit
unbiased but I am a man who has a little
bit of Fame nothing like what Jonah
Hill's got thank God and I've also had
messages shared before so forgive me if
I do have a little bit of empathy for
what this guy is probably going through
right now although mine were different
men were very uh drunken stupid and
rather funny according to a lot of you a
lot this is a bit different I'm not
really sure what's worse still mine now
before we read the DMs I do think it's
important to establish a few things that
are different about this than normal
everyday life this guy is a movie star
right a woman he is with will have an
impact on his brand and therefore his
ability to get rules how people perceive
him he does not want a Jada Pinkett or
Amanda Heard situation where he's got a
woman acting wild and making him look a
tit in public I'm not saying that this
makes the messages okay I'm just saying
it is expected that he has to lay out
ground rules a little bit more than a
normal guy secondly we only have the
messages that she selected we don't have
both sides so bearing in mind because
she's clearly tried to get him here this
is the very worst of him and none of her
worst whatever we're saying it takes two
to tango by that I mean like two people
have a crap relationship thirdly and
probably most importantly people who
take years to get over the Rex take zero
accountability then at a later later
date when that ex is now happy settle
down and having a child then try to
publicly destroy them ah it's very hard
to take the moral High Ground for you
here when you clearly are part of the
problem but we'll read the messages
because I've deliberately tried to avoid
them to get a full picture of them fresh
in front of you a lot so he starts by
saying plain and simple now I'm assuming
this is a long-running conversation
that's been had where he is finally
summarizing everything that they had
been discussing a bit weird to do it on
a text message for both of them it shows
a lack of maturity and it is a
horrendous way to communicate but I
suppose she can come back to it and
reference it if she needs to make sure
she's on point here so if you need
surfing with men she is a surfer
boundaryless inappropriate friendships
with men who defines inappropriate I
guess he does if you need to model or
post pictures of yourself in a bathing
suit I mean bathing suit pictures can be
some of them can be very ordinary and
then some of them can be very like you
know how they be on Instagram we've all
seen it sometimes I just lose half an
hour just looking at them it's more like
an hour
to post sexual pictures what's a sexual
picture I'm gonna search Google Now
sexual picture
ah friendships with women who are in
unstable places and from your wild
recent past Beyond getting lunch or a
coffee or something respectful he's
basically saying if she's a bit of a
slug right
she's going to lead you down the wrong
path I don't want her involved because I
don't want that kind of energy around me
a lot of men do think that sort of stuff
but this man put his dick on the table
and he's saying look I'm not having it
anymore and I'm not saying that's the
right thing to do but it's what a lot of
men think because we know when the
minute anything goes wrong you have some
women who will support your relationship
tell you to stick with them and and give
you good advice to try and help the best
of the relationship but those single
Queens who will be single until they're
50 who literally can't keep in mind to
save their life and they only say men
after 10 30 we all know the kind of
advice they're going to give you you
don't need that guy he's a waste of
space why don't you come up with me
Friday night well Sean they don't know
how to cook for a man they ain't even
making a sandwich they don't even know
how to put us in bread the only thing
they're buttering that's what's between
their legs I've gone off it it's not
even we're not even through the DMS yeah
he's basically saying if any of that's
happening I'm not the right partner to
you if these things bring you to a place
of happiness this I support it and there
will be no hard feelings these are my
boundaries for a romantic partnership my
boundaries with you based on the ways
these actions have hurt our trust so
he's talking about previous instances
with things that have caused issues that
he wants to avoid in future a bit weird
yeah a little bit weird like I mean I
think we all know that there's thirst
traps out there that women could versus
just a natural looking holiday
photograph and there's a if you're
poking your ass out towards the camera
then we all know you're waiting for them
dams to flood but this is this looks
like a man who's probably had enough and
the question is I guess after reading
some of these is is this just two people
who are very different values or is this
a man as some people have accused them
of of just being a very controlling
abusive partner I think that's a little
bit much you know like some of these are
a little odd and a little over the top
but I wouldn't call these abusive yeah I
don't want you to have trash bags for
friends and I'd rather you keep your ass
off the internet and I'd rather you not
have friendships with men that aren't
you know respectful and guys who don't
know where the line is a lot of men kind
of would want to ask for this sort of
stuff but just aren't in a position of
power and let's remember Hollywood movie
star he is harder to replace in this
scenario than she is if the if this was
the other way around she's Beyonce and
she's dating a guy who's just some
ordinary guy she would be in a position
to make more demands than he would
that's just power dynamics of
relationship that doesn't exonerate him
from actually making them I'm not saying
that that makes it okay but that's why
you can do this you know he's a catch
more than she is in this scenario she's
now posted this picture which says
Reviving a pic I took down by the
request of a misogynist narcissist I
don't think he should have had a problem
with it think about the definition of
this a person who dislikes the spices or
strongly prejudiced against women not
really saying that from from that I've
actually done a podcast on narcissism
and uh you know narcissists who have
their mental health condition and having
unreasonably high sense of their own
importance the issue with this is he is
a movie star he was in Wolf of Wall
Street he was one of the main guys this
guy's been a lot of [__] right so like
he is important so like it's a bit like
the Kanye problem a little bit like
Kanye acts like a narcissus it's like
with Kanye West though like but I I
don't think any of this is Kanye level
this is a warning to all girls if your
partner is talking to you like this make
an Exit Plan you don't need an exit plan
you can just break up with them I don't
see at any point in all of this him
having a gun to her head coach
that's off the internet you won't hang
around with me like he's literally going
look if you want to do that you can do
that I just don't want to be with you if
you're going to do that that is a lot
more reasonable than the way she's
putting this across don't get me wrong
not saying the demands are normal but
the way he's made them isn't exactly
like threatening so he's saying yes one
that isn't of your ass in a thong not a
thong but K yeah we've all had that
response from a woman and as far as the
other pictures in a bathing suit surfing
or not meaning he doesn't want any of
them she said not a thong but Kay is
says I'm done there's tons I'm just
going back the past month you don't you
want to argue and I don't he's basically
saying look I'm not going to go over
every single picture and challenge you
on them you know my values you are a
smart intelligent woman and you should
be smart enough to go back and go he
wouldn't like this this and this I
either want to you know be in his life
and I respect his values and want to be
a part of this or we're completely
different people and I'm gonna move on
and find someone who does appreciate
those things I do think that also it is
weird that he is doing that because bro
there's many other women out here who
you don't need to transform into sharing
your values why are you trying to turn
an Instagram babe into a housewife it
ain't happening bro but we've all been
there don't get me wrong but it ain't
happening she's titled this one you make
me sick uh he uh she says that makes me
feel like you're testing me to see if
you should keep me around or dump me
because there's something wrong with me
like I'm a nerdy doggy underwear naive
idiot socially he replies those are your
words not mine it just shows how calm he
is by compared to the way she's like
really making this a huge issue because
she's just fighting and fighting and
fighting and he's just setting the bar
going look these are my terms because
they're both playing into this you know
she's trying to be with him but fighting
him he's trying to be with her but
fighting her and without having all the
messages like they're just a terrible
match so far one thing I will give him
about you know this bathing suit issue
for example is like it is a little bit
normal I would say for a man to come
into a woman's life and go okay when you
were on the market and you were trying
to attract men you had a pattern of
behavior here which would make men more
likely to message you I think it's quite
reasonable to expect women to deviate
from that and tone it down and be like
okay now I'm in a relationship there's
going to be less skin unsure I'm gonna
act you know a little bit more
respectful than my guy because I am a
woman who's in a relationship now is he
going overboard I think that's fair if
you want to say that but I don't think
that the concept of asking someone to
change their behavioral pattern a little
bit when in a relationship is out of
order he says I respect your love of
Surfing but I respect myself as well and
your love of Surfing and being in those
situations and a lack of awareness are
not mutually exclusive so what he's
meaning there is look yeah I respect you
love surfing but you're you're using
that as a way of breaking boundaries
getting yourself in situations that make
me uncomfortable surfing and talking to
these guys who don't have boundaries and
putting your body on Shore it's not
necessary you can suit up fully in a
surfing uh thing and not talk to all
these men but still do surfing
um I'm not saying that that is right but
that's I think that's what he means if I
could have one wish for him it would be
that he's surrounded by feminist men who
can hold him accountable what she really
means there is I want him canceled like
that is just the obvious truth let's
think about this right and I'm not
saying the previous thing she didn't
have a point but you have waited until
this man is Hobby Set settle down has a
baby now and is living his best life and
you owned you aren't feeling that so
you're trying to tornado the [__] out of
this man's happiness that's what you're
doing I hope my ex has a daughter maybe
she'll turn him into a real feminist see
this sort of [__] is really weird the
fact that she's even mentioning his
daughter in stories is [__] crazy
this is a conversation with a friend of
hers basically saying that the therapist
would always side with him or whatever
yeah I mean the fact that they were in
couples therapy and they weren't even
together what a year not even I'm not
being funny but like if someone's
mentioning your couples therapy and it's
like you know six months to 12 months in
a situation get the [__] out here's
another one with a lovely diamond heart
around it and it says someone being an
emotionally abusive partner doesn't mean
they're a terrible person often stems
from their own trauma and at the same
time it doesn't mean it's okay well well
she really nailed that one but the
reason all of this has been posted if
you're wondering is she said sharing
this publicly now because keeping it to
my self was causing more damage to my
mental health than sharing it ever could
um [__] was it a bit controlling
yeah a bit weird yeah was it anywhere
near the worst thing I've ever read
about a toxic relationship nowhere close
yeah I've seen one comedian Twitter if
this is abuse then I should be charged
with crimes against humanity and she is
just looking to be the victim here and
feel sorry for herself but the reality
is she's just not over him and that is
obvious so obvious all those beautiful
pictures of him and his new baby have
got her triggered the [__] which is why
the caption on one of the first social
posts was [__] it and what does that
mean [__] you [__] your life [__] your
newborn child [__] your mental health
[__] your relationship and [__] your
happiness because I can't bear it that's
what that all meant I'm not saying this
guy isn't you know a shitty relationship
guy okay not saying that but she is 100
going for the kill here and he is
blissfully moving on with his life who's
the purpose a Trader women are doing
this a lot they're leaking these
messages they're trying to damage a
man's entire future and change the way
men are looked at forever it is one of
the slimiest snakeiest rotten things a
person can do but because women in
society are seen as the victim generally
speaking over men because a lot of the
time they have been right but but it's a
generalization that just is it shouldn't
be applicable to every single scenario
women just get away with this oh it's
fine because she didn't physically hurt
him so what they don't violently Hit Men
but they do try and ruin your [__]
life and have everybody for the rest of
your life look at you like you are a
misogynist controlling abusive bloke
when reality is this was an entire
year-long relationship we are taking a
few tiny messages exchanges from the
worst possible points of their
relationship to make him look horrendous
and not no accountability from her this
isn't even realistic it's not reflective
of their relationship and yeah it's tea
and we're all going to have a bit of a
nose and say oh that's interesting and
but this is bang out of order and any
man who goes with a woman who was
capable of not being able to move on and
to try and destroy a man's life from
moving when he's trying to move on and
have a child that woman is poison and
you're a [__] mug if you go there
afterwards because she'll do the same
thing to you because what she has proven
in amongst all of this even with a baby
involved is [__] it my feelings are all
that matters nobody else's I'm not even
saying that what he said in the in the
messages was okay but he wasn't trying
to destroy her life what she's doing is
far worse than anything I've read from
what he was saying to her you know if
men did this we'd be locked up if women
are watching this I think have some
self-respect because it doesn't make you
look good it just makes you look salty
and that you're actually beneath the
person you're doing this to it makes you
look like you can't let go of them
there's no sadder than someone who's
stuck in an ex relationship with an ex
while the other ones moved on doing life
and letting go so get the [__] over it
right because you're better than that
you're gonna get another guy maybe not a
movie star maybe that's why you're
triggered however
just be better yeah and there's my
advice hopefully you've enjoyed this
video if you have and you like more
common sense sort of chat like this I
talked so much about general
relationship problems in my last podcast
go and check that out with the men's
mental health expert Elise Michaels one
of my best podcasts today don't forget
to subscribe thanks for watching like
the video and I'll see us later have you
ever had a female pull your pants down
and go
well we've all been there one of the
reasons might be that you've not got
manscaped there are other reasons but
this isn't that kind of advert you see
in this heat wave even for the hairiest
of hairy men out there we've got the
beautiful little bundle of joy known as
the performance package 4.0 included in
this you get the essential lawnmower 4.0
the trimmer on this is a ceramic blade
designed to cut hair on loose skin and
let me tell you this works so well I got
on the scales afterwards and lost the
stone and it also comes with the crop
preserver ball deodorant to stay
especially fragrant in this clammiest of
Seasons you also get the boxers 2.0
without a doubt the best boxers for men
of all ages and there's also this great
little lecturer which is the shares 2.0
nail grooming kit including stainless
steel nail cutters tweezers and grooming
scissors so you're just going to make
sure everything's on point so that when
you're going out this summer not gonna
make a good impression you are clean and
sharp my guy so come on Lads sort
yourselves out it needs to be done and
why not do it in style use my code
t-r-u-e that is block capitals true at
checkout at manscape.com the link is in
the description below you'll get 20 off
free shipping